-Pierce, looking fantastic
as always, buddy.
Look at you on the cover
of "GQ" magazine
right here, by the way.
-Yeah, that's sweet.
-Yeah, I mean, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's the boys inside, though.
Those are the ones, my boys.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yes.
-They're inside, as well.
But, look --
come on, let's go back to you.
-Thank you.
-Tonight is about you.
What is it like
to be so good-looking?
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's get to the -- let's get
to the hard-hitting question.
-Yeah, well,
long may it last, Jimmy.
Long may it last.
-Yeah.
-So far, so good.
How you keeping?
You're looking all grown up now
with your beard.
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy with a beard.
-Yeah, thank you very much.
-It's cool, man.
-It is cool.
-It's majestic.
[ Laughter ]
You're the greatest, come on.
-It is, man.
-I love having you on.
I love talking about your
painting, by the way.
You know I'm a big fan of
your paint -- your paintings.
-Thanks.
Appreciate it.
-They're gorgeous.
And you're actually
about to have your first show.
-May 13th.
That's it, next year.
I've postponed this
so many times because of work,
and so, finally, I've said,
"Whatever movie I'm doing,
I'm going to do the show."
Santa Monica, May 13th.
-You're doing it.
-I'm doing it.
-Are you nervous?
-Well, not now,
but I will be then, probably,
you know when --
-How many years
have you been painting?
-Since, I'd say, '87.
-Yeah.
-1987.
I mean, I'm self-taught.
-You're so talented.
We want to show a couple,
just so we can see --
-Yeah, go ahead, man.
Go ahead.
-This one I --
This one I actually love.
I wish --
This one's called "Ear Plugs."
-Yep, painted.
[ Laughter ]
It's original.
-I don't know why
we started with this one,
but I do enjoy this one.
I really do like this.
-It is.
It's really nice.
I'm a big Lichtenstein --
Roy Lichtenstein,
a great artist.
-Yes.
-I'm a big fan of his work.
And I painted it
when I was doing "Goldeneye"
down at Leavesden Studios.
-Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did you used to have --
I'm assuming --
[ Applause ]
I'm assuming you'd have
to wear ear plugs
for a lot of the scenes.
-Well, yeah, of course.
I mean, you have to --
they give you these
little packets every time
there's explosions.
And so, I thought
I'd just paint it.
So, over six months,
I painted that.
-You made it into a work of art.
I love that.
-That's it.
-This one is "Picasso."
-"Picasso."
He is --
you know, he influences me.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
I'm very...
-I know, right?
-...appreciative of his work.
He's a great inspiration.
He is -- you know,
it all begins and starts
and ends with Pablo.
-What got you into art?
-I -- I --
Oh, God.
-Do you remember your first
time, you go like, "Oh, wow."
'Cause I --
-Well, I left school at 16, 17,
with nothing but
a cardboard folder
of drawings and paintings.
Got a job in a little studio
in Putney, South London,
and I thought,
"I'm off to be an artist."
And then I discovered acting,
or acting discovered me.
-Yeah, exactly.
-You know?
-Thank God
you made those choices.
-Thank God for that.
-No. We're so happy.
We love that. I mean,
congrats on the art show.
-Thanks.
-But, I mean,
you're Pierce Brosnan.
I mean, you've kind of
done everything, buddy.
It's fantastic.
-Well, it's work in progress,
Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-You know, it really is.
You know what it's like.
-But now --
Now you're a superhero.
-Now I'm a superhero.
I didn't expect this.
-Now you've actually
done everything.
You really have.
I mean, this is fantastic.
-Yeah. I really was --
It was the last thing on my mind
to be playing a superhero
like Doctor Fate.
-Doctor Fate.
What a cool superhero.
I mean, did you ever think,
like, "Oh, yeah,
I would do these --
I would do a superhero movie?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No.
-If the right one came along?
-You would do one?
-Oh, no,
I would never do one, no.
No one would offer me one.
[ Laughter ]
But, I --
That's not an option for me.
For you, I'm assuming everyone
offered you a bunch of things,
and you're like, "Well, hold on,
I'm not ready to do this."
-No, not really. No.
I mean, I went up for Batman
way back in the day
when Tim Burton was doing it.
-Oh, really?
-Obviously I didn't get the job.
But...
-Yeah.
You had to settle for
James Bond, sorry, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so sorry, yeah.
-I remember saying something
stupid to Tim Burton.
Like, I said -- I said,
"You know, I can't understand
any man who would
wear his underpants
outside his trousers."
[ Laughter ]
And so, it's just like --
-That is very interesting.
Yes.
-But there you go.
The best man got the job, and,
you know, Doctor Fate and I
were meant to meet
on the same page, I think.
-This is you as archaeologist,
Kent Nelson, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-And then, when you put on
the golden Helmet of Fate,
you become Doctor Fate.
[ Cheers and applause ]
My question is,
when you're wearing this,
and you can be honest with me,
can you see anything?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
No.
-Nothing at all?
-Everybody wants to know what it
was like putting on the costume.
What was it like
putting on the helmet?
You know, you can't see a thing.
It's darkness.
I mean, there were two helmets.
There was this stylish,
gorgeous-looking, sleek helmet
that's in the other photograph.
-Yeah.
-And then there was one
that I could actually
physically put on.
But, of course,
you're standing there
in a mocap suit --
a motion-capture suit, which is
the most inelegant and kind of
humorous thing to wear.
-Yeah.
Ping-pong balls everywhere.
-ping-pong balls, grey tights,
you know, you got to have
a sense of humor.
And I won't say it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yep, of course.
We said it for you.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Yeah, we're all good.
-But I remember
Jaume Collet-Serra,
the director, he said --
There was a point
where I had to find this crown,
and he said --
I'm standing there,
and I'm giving it my best
heroic acting, and he said,
"Okay, put the helmet on."
I said, "Don't worry.
I can see it. It's right there."
I put it on. Of course,
I couldn't see anything.
[ Laughter ]
-"We can't CGI that.
Yeah, go ahead.
Just wait.
Try one more take. Yeah."
-Anyway, it was good fun to do.
It was a lovely company
of actors.
I know you had
Noah on last night.
-Yeah. Dwayne Johnson's
coming on tomorrow.
-Dwayne is coming on.
Oh, good.
-I mean,
he's one of the greatest,
nicest guys you'll ever meet.
-Yeah.
-And to have such
a big following and such a --
being such a big star,
he's pretty humble, you know?
-He is.
-Which I do like.
Did you get that vibe from him?
-Oh, very much so.
We got on --
I mean, I got to know him more,
you know, on the press tour
than I did on the movie.
I mean, we had interaction
on the film set,
but he's a magnificent fellow.
He's kind of monolithic and
beautiful and owns this role.
-He is.
-Oh, he is.
-Yeah.
I'm just happy that you're
playing a superhero
in a giant, big thing,
'cause you know
I'm the biggest fan of you.
And we've talked about
everything.
But, now, you can go,
"Yeah, I've kind of
done it all now, yeah."
And this is the first of many.
'Cause I could see --
I could see where this --
-Well, slow and steady.
-Slow and steady wins the race.
-Slow and steady.
Yeah.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Pierce Brosnan
in "Black Adam."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-A wise man once told me
a bad plan
is better than no plan at all.
-That was before
we had a very bad plan.
-Let it go.
-I'd rather be fighting with him
than against him.
-What's the helmet telling you?
Somebody's gonna die.
Who is it?
Atom Smasher?
It's Atom Smasher.
-Surprisingly, no.
-Is it me?
-When it's time for you and I
to say goodbye, you'll know.
♪♪
All I can tell you is,
there's still time
to change the future.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
People will be cheering
in the crowd!
-Yes!
Pierce Brosnan, everyone!
-Go see it.
-"Black Adam" opens in theaters
and IMAX October 21st.
We're talking with Charlie Puth
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.